all right okay uh welcome everyone to
the ddps seminar uh today uh before we
introduce our invited speaker let's go
over some rules and Logistics first of
all please mute yourself during the talk
unless you have questions
if you have questions you are welcome to
mute and ask otherwise please use chat
room to post your questions so that we
can address them in Q a session at the
end second today's ddps seminar is open
to external audiences
therefore no classified discussion is
Allah allowed finally The Talk today
will be recorded
and upload it in our YouTube channel
um all right let's introduce our speaker
today it is an honor to host Laurie
Graham Brady who is a professor and
former chair of the civil and system
engineering department at Johns Hopkins
University with secondary appointments
in mechanical engineering and Material
Science and Engineering she currently
serves as director of the center on AI
for material materials in extreme
environments and associate director of
the Hopkins extreme materials Institute
our research interests are in machine
learning enabled mechanics models
uncertainty quantification computational
stochastic mechanics multi-scale
modeling of materials with random
microstructures and the mechanics of
failure under high rate loading she has
received a number of hours including the
presidential early career Awards of
scientists and Engineers the Walter
Hoover civil engineering research prize
and William Huggins award for excellence
in teaching she's a fellow of the asce
engineering Mechanics Institute and the
U.S Association for computational
mechanics today Lori will talk about ml
driven models for material
microstructure and mechanical Behavior
please enjoy and expect a wonderful talk
now without further Ado let me pass the
button to
Lori by asking one random question
today's random question is where is your
favorite place in the world
wow
other than here in my home that's a
tough one I've been to so many beautiful
places over the years you've got to pick
one so I gotta pick one well I got
married in Lake Placid New York so uh
and I have a lot of family history there
so Lake Placid is is a happy place for
me anybody hasn't been there I suggest
you go visit all right sounds good okay
Stacy's yours great thank you
uh so thank you youngsu for uh inviting
me and I appreciate everybody who is
here and
I hope I can deliver on the wonderful
talk that Young Sue just promised
um but it's a pleasure to talk to all of
you and I wanted to
um
start by giving oops sorry some credit
to the people who actually did a lot of
the work here including my group
including the PhD students and
postdoctoral Scholars some of which I
think might be online right now so
they'll uh catch me if I say something
wrong and as well as some of the staff
that have been really supportive of what
we're trying to develop here at Hopkins
uh so the motivation for all of this is
thinking about high throughput
data-driven design so I I'm going to
talk a little bit about something that
we're building here called the AI for
materials design in extreme environments
aimd facility and right now it's under
construction so I wish I had some
beautiful pictures of the lab itself but
right now it's pretty much drywall is
getting hung at the moment but it's a
2300 square foot facility and it will
integrate Material Science data science
Ai and Robotics and it's specifically
targeting right now metal alloys
although we're talking a little bit
about ceramics at the moment too but
what does it have so
in terms of fabricating and processing
materials we are planning or we are
using spotter deposition to generate
thick foils of these alloy specimens
using High throughput care x-ray
characterization where we can use for
example x-ray diffraction to understand
the crystal structure and maybe a little
bit about average grain size and x-ray
fluorescence to understand the chemistry
of the specimens that we're looking at
um and then finally thinking of extremes
there's High throughput laser shock so
with that we're looking at being able to
run tests multiple tests a minute
and characterize things like Spa
strength and hel
and some equation of State parameters
so that's on the sort of physical side
all of this is
getting integrated
it's not
okay all of this is integrated through
robotic automation so maybe I'll give
you some fun videos of what we're
talking about here so this is what the
layout will look like it's sort of a j
shaped conveyance that will move
specimens from one piece of equipment to
another and the robotic arms will be
placing the equipment in and removing
the or placing the material in and
removing from the equipment
and this is what it looks like in
reality this is actually at the vendor
they're still working out some of the
Kinks and we'll be delivering it when
the room is ready for it
and the roboticist and our team Axel
Krieger has developed some simulation so
on the left you're seeing just a video
of what we call the robotic arms dancing
but it gives you an idea of that there's
sort of multiple things happening at the
same time and if you look at one
particular equipment so this is the
X-ray system
um and going through the simulation of
how do you get a small specimen how do
you pick it up how does it get
transmitted into the equipment
um with an x-ray you have a very small
aperture you don't want a lot of open uh
apertures to the uh out the environment
outside for safety reasons so that
actually takes a lot of work to think
through those processes so we have a lot
of robotics
in play
the other piece that's really taking a
lot of time is thinking about data and I
think this is a huge challenge for
everybody there's a coordinated data
there's controlling the equipment the
metadata about the materials Gathering
and organizing and collecting the
results
that we can use to make on-the-fly
decisions about the processes that were
the experimental processes
and so just to give you some idea of
all that's involved in the data on the
left hand side is representing physical
systems so
um
profilometry laser shock x-ray systems
and Robotics in the middle is the host
machine this is the machine that's
controlling everything
um and so you can see the little person
is in the application Service as and
then there's all these acronyms here
data services in the middle that's
basically Distributing and moving data
and then Arch is the sort of off-site
facility where we send data and there's
an AI driver in there that we're working
on local Computing and so just to give
you an idea if you come up with a script
of something very simple to do all the
steps of where data has to fly from one
place to another in this system we have
to think through all these connections
and make sure that they're all formatted
in a consistent way
so never underestimate the data
management process
but beyond that to get to the meat of
what I want to talk about is that that
AI driver in there is going to need fast
computational models and some measures
of uncertainty in order to be able to
make effective decisions
now
the models actually don't have to be
perfect what they need to be able to do
is say that the model will predict that
situation A is better or different or
worse than situation B
but it doesn't necessarily mean that the
model has to be able to predict the
result down to you know Precision 10 to
the minus 8. it's really
um in this environment kind of a design
Discovery environment
it's a prediction of will something
change
so we can be a little bit looser in how
we
the Criterion we put on our models
so
what are the opportunities here and and
why now so why develop something like
aimd and I will note that there are a
lot of AI for materials facilities out
there that are really successful I think
what's different about ours is that
we're trying to capture extreme
environments Dynamic environments and
that's traditionally something that
hasn't been easy to do in a high
throughput setting
um so I think the opportunities here are
a few that there's certainly a greater
availability ability to develop new
materials so things like um
additive manufacturing and advances in
sputter deposition really enable a lot
of new materials
there's High throughput characterization
and testing we're talking about
processes that traditionally might take
hours or days being able to be done in
um seconds or minutes
or alternatively maybe surrogate tests
that are very fast that we hope
represent something about a larger
system
we have more computational power than
ever I always put an asterisk on this
statement because no matter what we
always want more computational power
let's say we have as uh
scientists and Engineers we have the
ability to fill the available
computational power with no problem and
I think that could go on to infinity
and then finally the uncertainty
quantification tools are maturing and I
don't mean to claim that this is a
mature field that it's you know all the
good work's been done but it's gotten to
the point where it's actually
practicable you can actually start
implementing uq practices in in real
problems
and so just a little right showing one
example of very complex model
so in red I'm going to give the
counterpart to each of those
opportunities sort of the challenge that
it presents we can develop many more new
materials but it creates an enormously
High dimensional design space so if you
think about an hea that has say Five
Element components there's an enormous
number of possible combinations of those
and certainly the full Continuum of all
the um
proportions of those
High throughput characterization and
testing is terrific it creates large
quantities of data that we have to deal
with we have to deal with those data
flows and typically that data is low
Fidelity so you're balancing sort of
high throughput low Fidelity data with a
little bit low Fidelity or High Fidelity
but very sparse data and so there's a
tricky balance there
um
true multi-scaling real models of these
systems are often computationally and
feasible even with a lot of
computational power so we need clever
ways to attack that and finally uq
adds cost
we're finding some very good tools but
it but it is costly so I can't address
all of those in this talk
um but I do want to think about the
issue the slow models do create a
bottleneck for design decisions so if
I'm thinking about our aimd facility
if
the laser shock system is sort of asking
is it worth testing this particular
specimen
and I send it to a model that takes 24
hours to answer then I've gained no
value from the fact that laser shock can
happen in minutes
and so I don't want my models to be so
slow that any decision that's made is
waiting on some long
um slow running model
I need to have fast decisions
so I think today I'll focus on these two
particular pieces one is how can we
enhance the data we have
so for example can we enhance low
Fidelity data to create High Fidelity
data
and how can we address multi-scaling in
a way that's efficient
so I'll start with the first one it's
kind of a talk in two parts
so here's our problem statement if we're
given limited three-dimensional or even
only two-dimensional data
could we reconstruct a three-dimensional
microstructure
or better yet an ensemble of those
so often in particularly in a high
throughput setting you're not given
three-dimensional information
is there a way for us to take the
two-dimensional information and generate
microstructures that have similar
characteristics so again our goal is to
generate an ensemble of microstructures
that match what are key characteristics
of the microstructure are not the same
microstructure a different instantiation
of the same kind of microstructure
and one challenge we face is that
traditional stochastic simulation does
not work well
so there are a couple of challenges here
say a binary material like this is very
non-gaussian in its distribution right
it's uh basically two direct Delta
functions which is maybe the extreme of
non-gaussianity so things like
translation processes to generate
microstructures won't work
or at least won't work very well
the other issue is that these kind of
irregular microstructures aren't as
simple as maybe a model where you would
say I'm going to put you know circular
inclusions down in space randomly you
can't use that here
so what are some description descriptors
that we might want to think about
um
one could be something like the two
point uh probability function which
basically asks if I put a vector down
randomly in the space what's the
probability that it's two endpoints lie
in four space and so on the right upper
right you can see uh
basically a typical probability function
its maximum is at Delta X Delta y both
equaling zero meaning you're comparing
the point to itself so it makes sense
those are a point is very well
correlated to itself and that sort of
correlation dies off as you go further
away from the the vector gets longer and
longer
another characteristic you might think
about is a pore size distribution which
basically says if you pick a random
point in the pore space
what is the distance to the closest
solid space
and a typical function looks something
like what I'm showing here kind of
starts at a peak
at zero and dies out as you go to longer
and longer distances
now a problem here is this it two point
probabilities don't often capture all
the characteristics so these are some
results from um actually a fairly old
paper
where a student and I were working on a
simulated annealing approach to simulate
these microstructures and we wanted to
match the two-point statistics so the
upper row is the original
image
the second row is a simulated image and
the two-point statistics are the same
between the first and the second row and
what you see is it's okay for the
circular inclusion microstructure on the
left the first one but if you look at
the other three there's a lot of
information lost shapes connectivity
you see glimmers of what the original
microstructure was but it's really not
the same at all
and we kind of hit a point where we said
well we tried using three-point
correlations and then improved the
problem improved the simulation somewhat
but it was incredibly slow to do that
um
and in the end it came down to like
things that we see as people we say well
this is more squiggly or that's more
connected but that's not so easy to
quantify so the what is missing question
kind of hung out there until we started
looking at some of the tools out there
related to machine learning
so the idea here is to use transfer
learning
the vgg 19 network is a network that's
commonly used for recognizing objects so
is this a picture of a cat or a truck or
an airplane
and it performs that recognition through
a series of finding just all sorts of
features that I don't even know there's
no way to describe them physically but
it just works with that image and
identifies all the relevant features
that would make it categorize into being
a certain object
so you can think of the same thing with
microstructure we input a microstructure
image and the vgd19 model gives us a
sense of the feature Maps
a bunch of aspects that we don't
necessarily know how to describe but
they're quantifiable
and so how we can use those networks
is let's say we have a Target image that
we would like to create another image
with the same characteristics
so we can take the target image and run
it through the vgg 19 model
and we can do the same thing with a
simulated image and we can just start
with white noise and compare the
uh Grim bases gram Matrix for each of
them and the loss is the difference
between those so that loss tells you how
far away is my sort of initial
simulation from the Target and there are
other things that we can add to this
loss function like total variation which
is basically penalizing
individual pixels like noise so it's a
way of sort of reducing noise in the
image but you can put whatever you want
into this loss function
combine it together to identify total
loss different again essentially
difference between the Target and where
you are with your current image and ask
have I minimized have I is the loss less
than some threshold
if it is well great we're done we have a
reconstructed microstructure that has a
lot of the statistics or the
characteristics of the original
if not then I need to update and
basically the algorithm uses a gradient
based optimization sort of an atom
Optimizer to update that image and then
we do the comparison again and we just
keep going and iterating and changing
that image and until it matches our
Target image in some reasonable way
um this actually was drawn from some
work by Wei Chen's group at Northwestern
where they just looked at the Grand
Matrix loss and we've been playing with
what goes into the loss function in
addition to that
all right so um
I'm just gonna
thing there
um
so this optimization based
reconstruction we match the statistical
descriptors
and the vgg 19 feature maps from the
target another thing that we added to
the loss function was the two point
probability so we wanted to actually
minimize the difference in the two point
probability between the original and the
reconstructed
and on the right you can see sort of a
Target on the left is a quick GIF of an
image going from White Noise converging
to a simulated microstructure so you can
see what happens is it iterates through
this process from
basically right now fuzzy white noise
through to a final image
and our final image we get a very good
match in things like the two point
probability function and the pore size
distribution function so those basic
statistics look really good
now that was just a single image another
thing we thought about was um
we have a sample that it's actually a CT
scan of a three-dimensional porous
ceramic and it has 180 it's one of its
Dimensions is 185 so we took each of
those slices and treated it as one
sample from the material so I think the
way to think about this is
you have a material that's all you know
some bulk of material it's all the same
material but if you looked at the
microstructure in one region and in
another region you will get different
microstructures
and so we wanted to capture that
variability so we went slice by slice
and you can see that there's a variation
in porosity and correlation length and
in mean pore size across all of these
and again this is the experimentally
obtained data the slices
and our question was do the
reconstructed microstructures capture
this and so what we did was for each
slice Target slice we generated uh
simulated slice
again you can see the Target and the
simulated are not the same thing but
they're statistically similar and we
went did that over the full 185 slices
and here we're comparing the Recon
distribution of porosity Coral length
correlation length and mean pore size in
the reconstructed in green
and the Target in blue
and if you look at the means and the
variances below each plot you can see
that
we're essentially matching definitely
the mean
with almost essentially no error and the
variance very well in each of these
distributions and the distributions
match over each other quite well now
again there's a statistical sampling
that happens here that would mean that
we wouldn't expect the distributions to
be exactly on top of each other because
these are different instantiations of
similar statistics
so we match those statistics but
is that really sufficient that was a
question that we asked ourselves and we
thought about the idea that the reason
you would typically want to generate
these virtual microstructures like this
is because you're using them to model
something so you're you would typically
simulate a microstructure put it through
some sort of finite element model to
develop some sort of prediction
um and so we thought probably a good way
to test this is to look at some average
properties that would be predicted based
on finite element models of the
microstructure so what we did is for
every microstructure that we simulated
we put it into a finite element model
um
with different properties for the black
and the white phase and I can't remember
exactly I remember that the black phase
was typically High values and the white
phase was low we didn't do full on pores
but just something with like a low
stiffness or low conductivity
um and so then we predict the stress
distribution
the heat flux distribution and the
discharge distribution
associated with each of those models
and overlaid that with predictions from
finite element models of the original
microstructures
and again you see there's a an excellent
match in the mean and the variance of
these quantities thermal conductivity
probably struggles the most
and maybe if I go back to that result
for a second
you can see the thermal conductivity in
the middle
it's very localized sort of Paths of
heat flux
so we would expect that that would be a
little more difficult to predict than
for example the Young's modulus which is
like an averaged sort of quantity so
that shows up here but even with thermal
conductivity there's a really strong
match between the simulated and the
actual microstructure statistics
so
what have we accomplished here
um
if you compare this to simulated
annealing which was sort of the more
traditional approach the transfer
learning here was orders of magnitude
less time and achieved significantly
Superior results so at some point we
just ran out of patience with the
simulated annealing and cut it off
before it converged all the way but this
was
um
we're talking
hours versus
minutes and the difference here so you
know a couple orders of magnitude faster
to get a very good multi-loss based
reconstruction on the left
we also were able to apply this to a
variety of multi-phase materials
thinking of polycrystalline kinds of
materials and get different kinds of
microstructures if you think about look
at the top and the bottom they're both
polycrystalline but they have sort of
different kinds of features and we're
able to capture that
so that's 2D
it's interesting from the perspective of
being able to generate an ensemble of
um
of microstructures but
really I think what's more exciting is
the idea of being able to go to full
three-dimensional microstructure
simulation so I'm gonna go back to the
3D reconstruction so this is our basic
image this is again that porous ceramic
we've been working with the image is
around 10 to the eight eight voxels
if we were to try to deal with this full
3d structure and optimize it uh we'd be
updating about 10 Megs of data at every
optimization Loop it would be pretty
memory intensive
and furthermore the vgg 19 and similar
models aren't really yet trained for 3D
images
so instead what we're doing is working
with 2D slices of this image and that's
much more easily paralyzed
so I'll show you some of the results
here
so here's the idea think about this 3D
structure
you start with white noise that's our
starting condition so every pixel is
randomly assigned black or white
independent of the pixels around it
and first we start thinking in the X Y
Direction and we take each of those
white noise images we run it through our
vgg 19 model the transfer model
and we update it so that it turns into
um
what's viable as a microstructure in the
2D slices now of course one slice is
independent of the next so you have like
within the slice it looks good but
across the slices it won't look as good
but so right now we have at this point a
deck think of a deck of cards each card
has a reasonable microstructure but it's
not necessarily correlated to the
microstructure through the cards
um so you would end up with something
like this actually it'd be even worse in
the first step because they'd be totally
uncorrelated but you have this sort of
bandedness that happens right because
what you did to one slice was
independent of what you did to the
previous slice and slice after it
um so this inter-layer noise occurs
um but it does converge over iterations
if we do the following if we take say
the slices with a light blue
and now that's our deck of cards in that
direction and we take each of those sort
of banded noisy images we make that the
initial condition for another transfer
model
transfer learning model we generate
microstructures in that direction
um and then we go to the dark blue
Direction because now that's a little
bit banded and strange looking and we do
the same thing we go through each slice
so it's kind of highlighted here this is
going in the X Z direction we basically
update the microstructure in that x z
Direction and then we update the slices
in the y z Direction
so in the process of doing this what
happened
um in the X Y Direction now we've kind
of messed up what was originally a
pretty good looking set of
microstructures within each plane
um so what we'll do is now go pass
through again go in the x y direction in
the XC Direction the y z Direction maybe
do three full passes five full passes
but what ends up happening is as you
move forward you're having to change
fewer and fewer voxels so you're
starting to see convergence in all three
directions
that ultimately
plays out into a good 3D model
based on the 2D image
so again this is starting from a single
2D image and saying if I assume that the
statistics are the same in all the
directions
I can go ahead and generate a 3D
microstructure based on those images
I could also have three images one and
one in the XY Direction one that's
collected in the y z Direction and one
is collected in the XC direction if it's
an anisotropic material
and I could follow the same process and
generate an anisotropic 3D
microstructure so I'm not limited to
just isotropic but that's what I showed
here
okay so the statistics of these 3D
microstructures
um look pretty good they get better and
better as we iterate more through the
model this is after three passes if we
went through five passes they might even
get closer
um so by three passes I mean that we
went
uh Direction one two three three times
so sort of nine passes to through in
different directions
and the pore size distribution also
looks very good in these 3D structure
we also use this to look at
polycrystalline microstructure so we
have we only had the 2D slice that you
see above the upper left
and from that we generated a
three-dimensional volume
that statistically uh has the same
characteristics as the 2D slice and
actually if you look at the grain size
distribution from
sort of 2D cutouts of the 3D Volume
they match almost imperceptibly they
almost exactly with the target
so these efficient simulations why do we
want them there are a few different
reasons one is uh the experiments are
typically
Limited in the amount that can be
observed right so maybe you have
A system that can only look at 128 by
128 pixels or
um so you're limited in the volume of
material that you can characterize at a
given resolution
but what this tool allows you to do is
to actually generate then
similar microstructures
that are larger you could go smaller too
but I think larger is probably more
motivating
so you're not as Limited in a model
based on the experimental observations
you're not so limited by what the
experiment is able to resolve
um
another piece that this enables is
looking at the uncertainty that's
induced by microstructure so you can
generate an ensemble of microstructures
and therefore get an ensemble of
responses so you can actually use that
to feed a model that would create or
would generate some sort of uncertainty
quantification
and then the third reason or the third
value of this is the ability to go from
a 2D image to a set of similar 3D
microstructures
so if you have a 2d reading of even in
different directions of what a
particular material looks like you can
come up with a reasonable
representation of what the 3D
microstructure might be
so that's my uh pitch for one piece of
trying to enhance data that's serving a
data-driven system like this
yes
maybe this is a good time to ask about
the first part yeah sure
but I have a question
you know the
the transfer learning the PCG 19 model
we you are using it is setting some
multiple loss functions and you have to
minimize it you said you use the
add-ons algorithm yes
that X that takes time right so the
computational cost of that it's it's not
free so when you compare the
computational course with a three point
three point
um you know
the methods of request reconstructing
the microstructure
all right which one is more expensive
but but you are aiming to come up with a
more efficient method so I guess
transfer learning must be more efficient
in some sense it is it's um
it's it's significantly more efficient
so in the
so that's simulating and annealing kinds
of approaches is that you're you're
typically doing some sort of pixel swaps
maybe in batch but you're kind of taking
small numbers of pixels and you perturb
them and then you ask is this new
version closer than the old version
um but there's no gradients in it so I
think what makes this approach faster is
using the gradient-based optimization of
the week step okay so it's sort of more
intelligently updating the
microstructure than
um I see but but still it it still takes
time right those VCC 19 model it's to to
solve that to minimize their loss
functions it does it's not like seconds
compared to two point method that's
that's faster
much faster yeah so it's
um you can accomplish a ballpark you can
accomplish what it would take an hour to
do with a simulated annealing kind of
approach it's in probably
um
I don't know half a minute
now over a large number of these and
over a large number of you know as you
try to converge it it still adds up so
I'm not saying that it's free it's not
something that comes up with no effort
at all but it just massively cuts down I
mean honestly how we got here was we
were trying to use simulated annealing
for simulating a 3D microstructure and
it just it was impossible we couldn't
get it to go where we wanted it to go
and so
my clever student went out and found
some interesting results in the
literature and we we started to pull
from that and actually found it just
made all the difference in the world
sounds good okay how many do you do you
have a question yes uh hi thank you this
is very interesting I I just have a
maybe a simple question I I've never
done anything about this before uh it
doesn't make sense or is it efficient to
like
reconstruct these microstructures uh
from K space like I would imagine that
two similar
microstructures would have similar
distribution in case space
um does that make sense or have you
considered something like that before I
haven't considered that that's a good
question
um
another reason why I'm thinking about k
space is that I would maybe also assume
that if you do a 2d slice and then you
measure like the k space distribution
then if you want to extend it to 3D you
can
just simply extend that distribution in
the other direction
and then I don't know like I'm just
thinking on the fly now yes
does that mapping work well in a binary
system
um
I actually don't know this is just all
of my imagination actually so I was just
wondering if you considered it in
k-space
it's it's actually it's a very good
thought I I think what would come up
is
um
these binary zero one systems are tricky
uh
oh
so you can match the statistics but
there's a lot of
um it would be a lot of noise some
things that you don't catch yeah
yeah
I mean yeah thanks
all right sounds good I guess I don't
know we can move on to the second part
of you excellent okay well and certainly
if if people think of questions uh
during the second part on the first I'm
happy to yeah later at the end yeah
sounds good
all right so um the next step is
thinking about multi-scaling and and how
could we have you how can we use machine
learning for multi-scaling problems
um and the idea here is what we need is
something fast a surrogate that can
enable real-time decisions and um
be able to link scales and maybe even
provide some uq this is actually a
graphic that I I lifted from kaushik
badacharya Caltech that I like just the
concept of you have a large box you know
large processor that can map inputs X to
outputs y but you want some sort of
small fast uh the
Raspberry Pi that can map from some
inputs to outputs in a much faster way
and so
you're all focused just on mechanics of
simple two-phase materials to
demonstrate an approach
um
through machine learning so let me start
just first with an overall problem
statement so you have some sort of
structure with some sort of load on it
in this case it's some sort of varying
pressure load
and that structure at the macro scale
has a micro scale that for now we're
assuming is some sort of simple
two-phase composite
and so if you wanted to go full on naive
you would say well I need a full-scale
finite element model of this system
within each element there is a local
microstructure and I'm going to mesh
that whole thing all of those 10 000
elements
and I can come up with something like
let's say this is a stress distribution
so yellow indicates high stress blue
indicates low stress and we capture the
macro scale variations in stress but we
also capture things like
um actually let me make a little
yeah laser pointer here
um you know Force chains
that travel through some of these
fiber Arrangements
now
clearly we all know this I think anybody
who's done any significant computational
modeling that's just not the way to go
we can't resolve everything at one scale
in the next scale at least not for
really interesting problems so the
conventional multi-scale fem approach is
to say well I'm going to take each
element
and I'm going to extract its
microstructure
use that to homogenize the material and
figure out some effective properties so
right now I'm sticking with linear
elasticity
um in a future direction as we move into
non-linear actually future slash current
but I don't have results for that that
I'm going to show today
so let's just stick with linear
elasticity and the material could be
orthotropic and come up with these
effective properties
you put those back into your finite
element model for each element and you
can get a distribution of average
stresses and you can see that there's
not a lot of variability in this that
doesn't come from the macro scale
loading though there are areas in here
and in here where there's some effect of
those variations in microstructure
but it's pretty small variations
what you can do now is take each element
and say well this element is undergoing
some strain state
that's predicted by the model and given
that strain State I'd like to figure out
what is the stress at the micro scale in
each of those elements so this is
basically a down scaling step going from
the upper scale to the lower scale
and so using a finite element model you
would take the microstructure apply that
strain that's associated with that
element that state of strain and you
predict some stresses coming out of it
and this is nice because it's
paralyzable it reduces the computational
time but it is still a lot of finite
element analyzes and it turns out to be
still quite costly
in particular you're having to sort of
resolve sufficiently the enter fiber
regions with enough of a fine enough
mesh to get some realistic results
so what we're looking at is a
representation that maybe uses some
finite element results so you do need
the finite element of results
as training data
but then being able to just take an
arbitrary microstructure and from that
to sort of take it in squeeze it into a
cube uh what Wally does with it and spit
it out into some uh stress so an output
stress distribution
so the first thing we need is the
training data and so I'll walk through
that and then I'll walk through the
architecture that we're talking about
for the machine learning
um so from the training data we need a
finite element model of the
microstructure so for each
microstructure
um you can imagine that we could apply a
unit 10 South Stream and come up with
three this is a plane stress problem the
way I've reformulated it that you have
three different stresses coming from
that the two axial plus the shear
and then you could apply a unit Shear
strain and again get three stress
distributions could also do strain
distributions if that's of Interest
and so now for each microstructure in
your training data you have six sort of
output data associated with that so we
want to train the model to be able to go
from microstructure to those six outputs
um we ran 50 models of the
microstructure and got basically 50
times 6
stress distributions
and then we were able to do one sort of
cute trick that helps
um so think about the original
microstructure this shows just six
fibers that's only for illustration our
actual calculations have more fibers in
each one but this just makes it easier
to see
so you have an original microstructure
that maps to some stress distribution
imagine that this is maybe an axial
strain and this is the stress in that
axial Direction
I can take that same microstructure if I
were to flip it around the vertical axis
the stress distribution would just be
also flipped accordingly
so because everything about the problem
is symmetric it's a symmetric loading
I can do the same thing I can flip it
around the horizontal axis again I just
if I say the microstructure were the
upside down
of what it was before the stress
distribution would just be the upside
down of that and then I can do it one
more time flipping again about the
vertical axis and so basically each
piece of data I can turn into four
pieces of data
um
it's there's no free lunch
this is it helps but it's not the same
as having an independent piece of data
but it actually does uh
give quite a bit of information to the
model so it's it would say the model
you know the model doesn't know the
physics it might look at the stress
distribution in the upper left and think
well something happens typically in the
upper right
corner of these models and what these
other pieces will do is sort of
eliminate some of that bias
so it sees that symmetry
all right so we have an augmented data
set now we have four times 50
microstructures and four times fifty
times six data even though we only ran
50.
and so the architecture we're looking at
is called a unet it's a form of a
convolutional neural net the idea is you
have an input image an output stress
tensor fields and the mapping between
those is through a series of
convolutions going down to a latent
space that then is decoded back up to
the output and then there's what are
called the skip connections that
basically recognize that there is some
form to the microstructure that should
influence what the results look like and
so it kind of brings some of the
microstructure and output connections
into play
um
and so what we're doing when we train
basically is training all the weights in
this encoder decoder process
and we get an input to Output mapping
of course once trained running any image
through this is like a trivial
computational effort
so unit predictions this is a
microstructure that was not part of our
training set
and this is the prediction of the stress
distribution that came out of that unit
model so the upper row corresponds to a
unit tensile load and the lower bottom
row corresponds to a unit Shear strain
and we can do a comparison between
finite elements and unit again this is
not part of the training set
so for this microstructure the finite
element prediction is shown on the left
the unit prediction shown in the middle
and then this gives a sense of the
absolute error uh the error is small
there's one region where it's higher
than the rest but even there it's less
than 10 percent
error so that's the stress in the
direction of the strain the transverse
stress
and the shear stress and so we have very
good agreement between them
similarly if we apply a Shear strain
we have very good agreement between the
two axial and the shear stress
and since I started with linear elastic
problems I can take advantage of
superposition so I can say
the total strain is a sum of some Factor
times to tensile loading plus the shear
loading to give me any general loading
condition I've got so if my finite
element model has a certain stream State
I can use superposition to find the
stresses for that arbitrary strain state
so very simple for finite Four Element
finite element model I don't suggest a
Four Element model to anybody but this
is just a nice illustration under a
tensile loading the unit can predict the
stress distribution in each of those
four regions under unit loading
and use that take the averages of those
to find the constitutive relations for
each of the elements
when those are put back into the finite
element model it gives us an average
strain tensor for every element and or
average stress
that is a result of variations in the
microstructure from one element to the
next we apply those strains
sorry to the unit model and we get a
stress distribution
and putting it all together looks like
this so this is again purely using the
unit model there's no finite element in
here other than the finite element model
two by two elements the macro scale
and if I compare that to a full-scale
finite element model where the fibers
are all exactly resolved
I have really great agreement and this
was like trivial on the right this it's
a two by two finite element model with
like simple implementation of the unit
um the only difference you see is along
here where there's the element boundary
but that's a problem in any
multi-scaling uh Paradigm so if we'd
used Fe squared we would have the same
thing anytime you extract part of the
model and analyze it separately you'll
have some discontinuity at the interface
and so we can show the same thing for
something with a much more refined mesh
this is the true stress map from the
full finite element model this is
predicted from the unit model this on
the right took seconds to run this on
the left took days to run but you get
all the same kinds of force chains that
you can see
and actually one thing I should point
out is you can kind of see a grid here
because there are no fibers on the
boundaries in the way we train the model
since then we did an analysis where we
looked at fibers that cross boundaries
it doesn't create any problems for the
unit so we can vary the volume fraction
we can vary the fibers sizes we can put
the fibers at the boundaries this is all
from a single trained unit model
and the predictions sort of this is I
should have labeled this sorry the left
I think is the finite elements and the
right is the unit model we get excellent
results in all these cases
so we can apply this to an arbitrary
geometry basic idea is macro scale
Behavior to
um
homogenize and get our uh
sort of average stress or strain state
run that through the unit model that's
trivially fast to run
and get our micro scale behavior and put
that back and we get a much richer
picture of the overall stress
distribution in this system
I think
um yeah so to conclude this deep
learning is terrifically fast and it's
accurate for predicting the micro scale
stresses
it provides a really efficient
multi-scaling approach or a composite
and some things that are in progress
inelasticity and or dynamic Behavior
we're tackling by treating that as sort
of a
an added Dimension to the problem so
it's another dimension that we'll have
to train for
we could also look at three-dimensional
microstructures so this was really just
showing you 2D it also enables deep
learning based uncertainty
quantification
both in terms of uncertainty of the
model predictions also another piece of
this is we're looking at uncertainty
quantification for the CNN architecture
so what kinds of uncertainties are
introduced by even using this model
and then finally the the
animation is showing you how quickly we
can analyze the system just moving
fibers around right so we can get the
updated stress distribution very fast
this made us think that there's a real
opportunity for thinking about topology
optimization here where you could think
about what it what should be the
placement of inclusions in a two-phase
system that would maximize or minimize
some particular Behavior
so those are all the things that
we're thinking about this is actually a
picture of the lab I was describing
earlier the aimd lab when it becomes
available so I don't think there'll be
shadowy figures hanging out so much when
it's up and running
um so we're looking forward to that
sometime this summer it's gotten a lot
of support from the University and army
research Labs has been a big supporter
of this and it's all run through the
center and AI for materials in extreme
environments so thank you any questions
thank you thank you so much for the one
wonderful talk Lori
um we do have a question Adam just raise
the hand can you commute and ask a
question yeah can you guys hear me yes
hi Lori this is very exciting very
awesome talk
um so it seems like superposition is
doing a lot of the legwork here for you
to be able to take the data if you train
for all those simple strain States and
extrapolate
um so can you talk a little bit about
your strategy when you go into
non-linear regimes or plasticity
something like that and are you just
going to need way more data or what
what's going on there yeah it's a good
question
um so there's a couple of different ways
to think about it one is if if you knew
if it's just a problem of it being
inelastic and you know the load path
you're traveling through it's actually
not too bad of a problem because you
could train it for example we could
treat the
um
the results is a three-dimensional
entity right where you have each slice
in three dimensions is the state as
you're loading up yeah so you could
capture that behavior
um and that's actually quite doable and
we've been able to accomplish some some
work there the challenge I think in
multi-scaling is that you don't know the
load path a priority so you don't know
this integration point is going to go up
here and over here and done and so I
think there has to be some training over
possible viable load paths and or
what I think is actually even more
hopeful is to think of it the same way
finding elements does right so you're in
a certain state right now and you're
advancing forward in a particular load
step sure so you'd have to think about
can I train my model to understand what
happens in in a load step
um so that it's not like having to think
about the whole path the load path that
it follows does that make sense yeah
yeah so it's at least one more Dimension
to your problem but possibly more
Yeah It's Tricky I think in the
multi-scaling
um so it's something that we're trying
to wrap our heads around right now and I
do think that the incremental
approach is probably the load increment
approach is the way to go okay thank you
very much
sure thanks sounds good
I have a
maybe brilliant idea to
oh I love it
so if you go to slide 61 yep 61.
so in order to enrich the data to train
the unit you you you you know take
advantage of the Symmetry right yeah
okay on top of that you can animate more
by just you know
translating the microstructure like
translation translational symmetric but
basically so you have a small unit cell
and then not just looking at the
individual Chunk in discrete sense why
don't you smoothly move right that will
create a lot more data and you know you
you do have the corresponding stress
fields
right so
it means that's another way of enriching
the data and then you know as everyone
knows younet or any other neural network
Big Data helps right so I think if that
will improve the unit and performance
um by and yeah yeah you're thinking kind
of a moving window over uh exactly
exactly yeah and and you know
continuation onto the Adam's questions
if you go to you know the time dependent
path dependence
um the material uh you said that you are
going to introduce the time window right
there you can also think about moving
the time window like
start with some small timing though I
mean you you do have the data for the
longer longer time but make it short and
then just translate slowly those chunk
and then you know build the unit on 3D
dimensional x y and and the time domain
and that's another video but when you
slide the window with the boundary
condition like because I assume that
here for each little blog
you apply some kind of uniform boundary
condition then when you slide the window
the solution is not a solution of that
particular boundary condition is that
correct that's right so yeah I think
you wouldn't have the same so what's
consistent here is that the boundary
condition is always that uniform strain
boundary condition
and we would lose that in a moving
window
but in a sense the flip so
um something I didn't really touch on
here is you can train this model on
these relatively small I wouldn't say
six fibers but maybe 20 fiber model
those are pretty quick analyzes to do
and you can and you can perform a number
of them
what's interesting about it is that it
captures enough of the local physics
that it actually has potential to be
applied to a much larger domain so in a
sense it's sort of the reverse of what
you're saying even so that you can
actually use training on these small
pieces to tell you something about a
large piece without even
without the full multi-scale finite
element framework around it it turns out
it tells you a lot about the statistics
locally even in a larger system
sounds good making sense and the other
issue I think with the time I think you
I get your point about sort of averaging
over time the challenge you run into
there is that it's not statistically
homogeneous it's changing with time so
what's happening in this part of the
time might be very different than what's
happening here so yeah
it's a good thought though
it is potentially brilliant I have to
think about that
sounds good hopefully it remains to be
brilliant
[Laughter]
all right is there any other questions I
just wanted to say to Henry's point that
once you go into a non-linear regime
you're not able to cleanly superimpose
these simple strain boundary conditions
anyway so knowing as long as you know
what the stress and strain on the
boundary of your window are and you
track that as well in the data that
might not be a huge problem
that's a good point
um if there's an advantage to having a
large system
that you have a model of and then you
want to sort of locally average across
you absolutely could you could measure
the
um stresses and strains on the
boundaries of those local regions just
the same way yeah
so now the idea remains to be brilliant
I think
exactly
sounds good
all right uh we have a question from C1
Tony yeah do you want to admit yourself
and ask yes uh thanks Laurie for the
great talk
um yeah I learned a lot but uh I want to
ask about the comparison of the follow
element prediction of the Neo Knight
protection uh I think is a field slice
uh behind this but I'm not sure uh so I
want to ask if you have any insights on
how to incorporate such like over
sampling techniques in the unit model to
suppress the resonance along along the
boundaries
um as we do in multi-scale file in
Memphis
so I'm not sure I completely got the
question you were talking about the
issue of maybe let me go to a
yeah
[Music]
um
I'm not sure if for example here yes so
you you say there is some like uh
discrepancies along the boundaries I I
don't know if it uh
if we describe the same same issues with
the same terms
um in like Reservoir simulation and in
like Material Science but uh so I think
this is called a resonance effects uh in
multi-scale Fire Island in Memphis when
it applied to like uh risk of
assimilations so uh we have like over
sampling methods to try to reduce the
resonance error but um
I'm not I want to ask if this applies to
your problems and do you have any
insights on how to incorporate these
techniques in the unit model
yeah you should be able to actually do
the same thing right so you could build
the unit model
to represent let's say you know
oversampled region yeah um and then
there's
you'll have overlap between regions but
you could do the same sort of I would
imagine even just sort of linear
filtering right you could sort of
average the
the results from two overlapping
subsequent unit models which I believe
that's what's done in the multi-scale
finite elements too
um or some you know more complex version
of that but
um yeah we didn't even think about that
and as I say I kind of didn't touch on
the fact that we found that in fact the
unit model is is more powerful than we
thought and we don't necessarily have to
even stick to this finite element
construct to get some pretty interesting
results but we just those results aren't
quite there yet so I I wasn't ready to
bring them up today but I think you're
hitting on exactly what we found too
there is some way to use over sampling
to kind of smooth out some of these
discrepancies at the element boundaries
thank you
sounds good okay a question from Tom Tom
do you wanna admit hi Lori thanks it was
a great talk
um have you applied any of these methods
to carbon fiber Composites seems like
that would be an easier problem because
you have the fibers that you know would
transmit uh stresses
yeah we didn't actually go to a specific
um composite system here here I think it
was some generic composite with
I can't even remember the contrast ratio
maybe 10 to 1 or 15 to 1 or something
like that
um
but there's absolutely no reason it
could be applied to any combination of
now elastic properties that we'd like so
it could absolutely be a carbon fiber
composite and I think actually thinking
about real Composites I think going to a
three-dimensional system
is really exciting because then we could
start getting into things like weave and
waviness and some of the outer plane
Behavior that's really important
thanks Lori
thank you is there any other questions
from audience
well if not let's thank Lori for the
wonderful talk and wonderful q a
sessions and hopefully there after this
talk there will be some collaboration is
going to go on between Lourdes Livermore
and Laurie your groups so that's that's
the whole that's the ideal I hope so I
enjoyed this very much and absolutely I
hope anybody who has any questions
should feel comfortable getting in touch
with me and you know maybe I would even
pass you on sometimes to some of my
students in postdocs who could really
get into uh they know all of the details
awesome awesome wow thank you Lori
thanks so much
thank you